donc des amalgames de plantes qui
retiennent la dope ses agencements de
plantes vivaces annuelles et indigènes
ne sont pas laissé au hasard
ce qui pousse à l'intersection du
boulevard laurentien gouin va permettre
de trouver les végétaux susceptibles
d'améliorer la qualité du sol pour
assurer la survie des nouveaux arbres
qu'on plante en ville ça pas jusqu'à 50%
des jeunes cons quand on perd c'est un
laboratoire que surveille l'équipe
délice beauregard une architecte
paysagiste spécialiste des sols
on veut créer des paysages qui
nourrissent le sol chicorée ciboulette
échinacée on cherche le bon assemblage
des agencements novateur qui ne
correspondent pas toujours aux critères
esthétiques des citoyens l'aménagement
conventionnelle sert de base de
comparaison
et au final on va mesurer aussi la
fraîcheur qui voit dégager
on va mesurer les retours de matière
l'instrument danseur puis on mesure
aussi on observe là parce que c'est sur
3 1 les plans qui vont qu'ils ont de
meilleur recouvrement
parce que ça c'est des gros facteur pour
diminuer l'entretien en finançant ce
projet pilote
la ville de montréal espère développer
des pratiques qu'on pourra reproduire
ailleurs
c'est laurent est un des arrondissements
qui compte le plus d'îlots de chaleur à
montréal on a donc appris à laisser la
nature faire son travail comme ce bassin
de rétention
intégré au parc philippe laheurte il y
avait de la végétation qui s'est
installée de façon ponctuelle
alors au lieu de larrazet de recommencer
on a décidé d'en profiter et de profiter
de magnifier même la biodiversité et
donc au lieu de tondre au lieu de de
s'occuper de contrôler la nature c'est
plutôt de la laisser aller et d'en
profiter
on a aussi cessé de tendre une grande
partie des espaces qui sépare les voies
de circulation
ces nouvelles pratiques ne font pas
toujours l'unanimité au début il faut de
l'audace il faut essayer des choses la
prairie urbaine autour de la
bibliothèque municipale est vu
différemment maintenant quand ça marche
ça marche tout seul
enfin 30 les gens se rendent compte que
au lieu de voir des plantes nuisibles et
gens commencent à avoir des fleurs des
papillons des abeilles par qu'on laisse
l'herbe assez bien mais pas des insectes
et des oiseaux au lieu de la vision un
angle ans j'ai au moins de chaleur
c'est aussi parfois le retour en ville
d'un bon monarque ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada à montréal